MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, my name
is Martin Omander.
And I'm here with you for Google
Root Access, the show
on Google Developers Live
about startups.
And I'm joined today by Don
Dodge, long-time investor and
startup advocate.
Don, we did a show a couple
of weeks ago about, how do
venture capitalists think?
And we got a question--
so you talked about revenue
is important.
You have to show revenue
to your investors.
And we got a viewer writing in
and saying, but is revenue
really that important?
It took five years for Google
to start getting revenues.
DON DODGE: Yeah, that's
a good question.
It really depends on the
investment climate at the time
that you're starting
your company.
And over the past 20 years, I've
seen the climate change
from being able to raise money
on just a business plan or a
PowerPoint presentation to
swinging to where you had to
have users and growth and
initial revenue and your
revenue model proved out.
So it depends on the investment
climate at the time.
Now in the case of Google,
Google started in 1997, I
think, something like
that-- '97, '98--
and didn't generate revenue
until sometime in 2000 or a
little later.
In that time period, that was
an acceptable thing to do.
However, in any time frame,
you have to demonstrate
innovation, growth, maybe even
hypergrowth, with a path
towards profitability, with a
idea of what your revenue
model will be.
And depending on the time frame,
you either have to
prove that out or just have
it as an idea, and
people will fund it.
In the case of Google,
there was
tremendous innovation happening.
And they understood that
eventually they would be able
to monetize the audience.
And of course, it worked
out very well.
Today the pendulum has swung.
And I see at Y Combinator and
TechStars, companies working
on much smaller ideas that
generate revenue quickly.
They're more
business-to-business type
ideas than the sort of consumer
or social-oriented
ideas that take much longer
to get to profit.
So it all depends on the
investment climate in which
you're starting.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you have to
balance cash flow against
innovation and sort of strike
the right balance.
Is that the way to
think about it?
DON DODGE: Right.
So on an earlier show, we had
Alex Moore, from Baydin, on.
And he went to cash
flow break even
directly from angel money.
So he was able to raise a little
bit of angel money that
gave him 12 months or 18 months
of runway and move
immediately to a revenue model
that got him to cash flow
break even.
And he never did raise
money from VCs.
So if you have the type of
product that can do that, then
you probably should.
But you need to recognize
early on, is this a
hypergrowth, viral kind of
product, or is it a steady
growth kind of profitable
product?
And then you need to adjust
your business model, your
growth plans, and how you
attract investors accordingly.
So you need to really understand
what kind of a
product and what kind of company
you're building.
Match that up with the investors
who care about that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hm, I see.
And on that note, matching
up with the investors--
investors, I guess, are
different in different parts
of the world.
What if you're a startup outside
Silicon Valley, where
the VC environment is
very different.
Should you then focus on
innovation or cash flow or
something else?
DON DODGE: Well, that's
a good question.
So it depends on the timing
and investment climate.
And those climates
can be different.
For example, the investment
climate in Silicon Valley, the
answer to that question
is obvious.
You focus on hypergrowth and
build users and customers as
quickly as possible, and that
will attract more investment.
And the idea is that eventually,
you can flip the
switch and monetize
that audience.
So that's been the sort of
operating model in Silicon
Valley for a long time.
In other parts of the world,
investors are more
conservative, and they want
to see the more--
like the Baydin model, where
you bootstrap building the
product, you get your initial
customers, you get to cash
flow break even, you prove out
your model, and then they'll
give you investment capital
to expand that growth.
So the risk is much lower, but
the returns are also lower.
So investors that have that kind
of mentality want to see
that business model proven out,
initial customers, and
then they'll give you money.
So I guess you have to balance
a couple of things.
You have to balance, what is the
investment climate like?
What is the timing like?
And then, if you're in different
parts of the world
where the investors are more
conservative, then you have to
take a more steady growth kind
of approach and prove out the
model and innovate at the
speed at which you can
generate profit.
So it's profit-driven innovation
rather than
innovation driving the
growth and profit.
MARTIN OMANDER: And learning
how the investors where you
are, learning how they think,
that requires networking,
hanging out with them long
before you actually go and ask
them for money, I assume.
DON DODGE: Absolutely.
So it works both ways.
Taking the Silicon Valley
hypergrowth, fast-growth
approach with investors in other
parts of the world is
probably not going to work.
And taking the slow growth kind
of less-risk ideas is not
going to work with Silicon
Valley VCs, because they want
to see $100 billion companies,
and they want to see 10 to 20
times their money.
You're not going to get
that from a more
conservative approach.
So you have to balance the type
of business you have and
the investment climate that
you're in and sort of set up
your business model and growth
plans accordingly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you very much, Don.
DON DODGE: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I'm a
developer, and I love
developing on the Google
Cloud Platform.
If you want to try it out, you
should get on the Cloud
Platform starter pack.
Details are on screen now.
We have a special offer for Root
Access viewers, where you
can get a $2,000 credit to get
started on the Platform.
Please sign up, try it out.
And please keep those questions
coming in and
comments on YouTube,
and we will address
them in future shows.
Thank you.
See you next time.